*Sad music*
The wall...
...behind me...
...is empty.
The wall...
...that once...
...stood by a great man as we all know and love as...
Ainsley...
...whatever his last name is.
Now...
...I have here
Ainsley's diary.
his last words...
and I know it's unethical for me to go through it...
[Sighs.]
but I need to know...
Where was his mind?
Where was his soul placed...
...before he ceased to exist?
Now, it's all written in Bhut- Bhutanese...
...up until the very last page,
so I assume that it was meant for me.
"Try not to laugh...
...Instagram edition."
[Blown out bass.]
Let's go through these links together...
I know that's what Ainsley would have wanted.
Ainsley just wanted me to watch memes?
What is this shit?
[Immediately laughs.]
I am so fucking shit at these!
Okay...
let me do it again...
The next one...
Let's get straight into the memes...
(video) Hello, I'd like to speak with a Mr. Snotball
First name: You're-a
[Inturrupts] You're a snotball?
What?! How dare you!
[voice changes] This person just sexua-- just--just spoke to me in a sexual harassing way
[Inhales]
That's disgusting!
I think I do-I think I do her voice pretty-pretty good...
Woman: "Humongous wot?"
"Humongous what?"
Woman: "Humongous wot?!"
"HUMONGOUS WHAT?!"
Woman: "DISGUSTING!!!"
Man [in Kermit voice]: "Hey what's up guys?"
Scarce here?
Man [in Kermit voice]: "It's Scarce *aka dumbass shit* here!"
Man [in Kermit voice]: "Today we have a lot of news..."
[laughing] No...
[laughing] No!
Man [in Kermit voice]: "It's gonna be a double upload..."
[Laughing] Oh, fucking hell.
I called it and still it gets me.
[Impersonating Scarce] A huge Youtuber...
You jus - you just gotta do Kermit and somehow it's the same.
I think we have some pretty big news today
[Gibberish, along with an overlayed Scarce video playing in the background.]
What the FUCK am I doing, Jesus Christ.
Alright, next video.
[Softly] Hey guys..
Aww, fucking hell, stop!
[video] Hey what's up guys, it's Sca-
No! No! No!
It'sa - it'sa - it's- it's done. Alright, the meme's old now okay.
You've - you've ruined it, okay.
I think you'd be more comfortable over at that place.
Weenie Hut Juniors ?!
Are you saying I belong at Weenie Hunt Juniors?
Uh - Oh no, sorry.  I was actually pointing to the place next to it.
Super Weenie Hut Juniors?!
[Felix, laughing]
Yeah, unless you think you're tough enough to fight me.
That's a good point. Uhh - from now on guys,
I'm just going to make...
Toy unboxing channels.
Family friendly content.
This is big news - I was wait with this big news,
but I'm launching a toy unboxing channel
together with...
Jacksepticeye.
It's gonna be called...
Wh - What's in the Jack-a-box.
And we are going to unbox...
Adult diapers.
At first glace, taking this tomato down through the
spinning fan blade may seem impossible.
It's a tomato!
But I needed to show you it's not.
[Lowly] Oh...
*YEET*
[Falling, loud crashing.]
Wait - what the..
the...
Someone got hurt and I didn't laugh?
Ainsley's death has really taken a toll on me guys.
Yo guys what's up it's Jacob-
Shut the fuck up, I will fucking laser you,
with alien fucking eyes and explo-
[Felix laughing.]
Where is that Kanye clip from?!
Kanye: "Shut the fuck up,"
Kanye: "I will fucking laser you with alien fuckin' eyes and explode-"
What the fuck kind of comment is that?!
Mayaishere
The fuck is this?
[Dog eating brocoli very loudly]
*NOM NOM NOM*
Why is that dog eating brocolli
[dog slurps]
EEEEEEEEEEEEHHHHHHHHH!
EEEEEEEEEEEEHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
I am so fucking bad at this...
Ainsley knew my weakness!
Retarded pugs!
Woman: "Hey, I'm Raylene, and I'm here to instruct you on how to give a really good blowjob..."
Retarded Guy: You ok?
Unknown Girl: What?
Man: "I'm just sayin..."
[launches hotdog]
I mean, I want the-
WHAT?!
What the fuck am I watching?
What the fuck is wrong with Ainsley?
What the fuck is those videos?
How do you even put those two together?
OoooOOOOOHHHHHHHHHhhh
*AY GUEY*
Oohhhhh...
...no.
Ainsley did not die for this.
*Sad piano music plays in background
[muffled] come back
[muffled] COME BACK DAMN IT!!!
OH shit, oh shit;
That was real fuckin' close.
AH! Motherfucking holes...shit...
Great! That's bended now-
That's fuckin'...great
That's just awesome
Fuck!
God damnit...
I squished my finger :(
"I've Fallen... [Music Interrupts] "So I'm takin' my time on my riiiiiiiide"
*tries not to laugh*
*Laughs* Thats perfect! I will never be able to hear that song again and not think about this, thank you very much
I need some good memes Ainsley.. okay..
ok.. give me some decent shit.
Gimme.... some decent shit
*Cheerful music plays as man slides across bathroom floor naked under a shower stall]
3..
2...
1...
*Plays same clip*
That's gotta be so gross for your penis
[Sarcastically says] Sorry, am I the only one thinking this?
Running your fucking dick on that type of floor
And do you want fucking warts on your  penis .... go right ahead
[background noises]
Hail Hitler
NO, NO, NO! We can't do that shit Ainsley! What the fuck?
No Nazi shit Ainsley! I told him that- I told him that.. man.. lets watch it again
Why would it just randomly do that?
*Call of Duty Music plays* "Mission failed! We'll get em' next time!"
[Laughs like duck]
[Inhales] awwh..  Got me!
*Piano plays in background*
Who made this?!?
WHO MADE THIS!
YOU THINK THIS IS SOME KIND OF JOKE?
AINSLEY IS NOT A NAZI!
DISGUSTING!
Wait a minute...
Ainsley's Diary!
It's dated 1942?
[Nazi soldiers marching]
No.
[Yelling]
Ainsley...was a Nazi spy.. all along.
But he was my NAZI SPY DAMNIT... HE WAS MY BEST FRIEND.
AND I KILLED HIM!
[Piano music increases volume]
[Piano music ends abruptly]
What's this!
A final note!
[Robot voice Reads Ainsley's last note.]
Felix.
Ainsley!
Ainsley : I have returned from the grave! Become Nazi with me!
Felix : Ainsley you Nazi piece of shit!
Felix : Fuck you!
Felix: I killed you once, ill kill you again!
Ainsley: Don't do this!
Felix: Burn in hell you piece of nazi shit!
Ainsley : Please... Stop!
Felix : You fuckin piece of shit!
Ainsley: No
Felix: Its what you fuckin get! Burn!
Ainsley : No... no.. Nien Nien-- Nien"
[Right Here Waiting plays]
He was too young to die